yeah i don't even know why is that
coordinated with all kinds of people you
know put a chain into a soup and then it
goes to a kitchen and if you have the
chain you run out hi my name is octave
durham nickname oki
i did more than 10 000 burglaries i
robbed everything you can imagine my
name is arthur brandt i'm from the
netherlands i'm an art detective i'm
responsible for recovering 250 million
of stolen art we now work together in
trying to befriend archives we are going
to look at diamond heists from hollywood
movies and we're going to watch how we
think we are
if you do this in real life inside
everybody would
would have been dead i guess
no but look at the mechanism as well i
mean it doesn't look like that
i did this a couple of times and they
don't open like that no way
you have a door
and there is a lock
on it but with two keys one from the
bank from the bank employee and one from
you but it's one piece
so if you cut this one out this one is
still here
if you have to put them both out and
then lift them up but the first time i
did it i had blisters this stick the
first time i did i couldn't use my hands
i uh
underestimated how much
power i had to use to open it and i
opened a few hundred so every time the
screwdriver was going in my palm of my
my hands were this thick
it really hurt
it takes at least
three four minutes to open one and the
small ones are very tough and the ones
who were on top because i can't put any
pressure if they were on this height i
can open them but if they were this
height i couldn't you know put any
strength on it or power so of a good tip
if you have a safety deposit in a bank
make sure it's small and it's on top
but what do you find in it
everything diamonds everything
everything you find diamonds gold pearls
but you only also
find very uh
heavy pictures and stuff like that that
you can really
you know i'm not into that but you uh
what's called extortion you could extort
really we see pictures or you see uh
people who have a
completely uh
they have a double life i took it back
and at that time i'm talking about
25 years ago it is it had only
videotapes
and at that time a videotape recorder
with a little screen so if you open it
you could see it it's like a laptop i
think he was watching adult movies in
safe you know
what why is it in the safe
most of the time there are an envelope
small ones it looks good in the movie
but i never found them like that i found
a lot of diamonds
official in books you know
what they are with the certificate next
to it i found books with
six diamonds each in it from let's say
have a carrot to one one and a half two
two and a half three and i found
six of these books they were worth one
and a half million swiss francs at the
time
i love colored stones
some diamonds with some special color
are very expensive but most of the time
especially the yellow ones are just
off-color diamonds you know they're not
worth that much most of the time they're
cheaper
unless they are flawless most of these
gangs they know people who can
sell these stuff you know they can say
this is good this is not and they will
sell it if they make you do a job like
this and they know you don't know
nothing about value you get screwed of
course
that's the diamond business anyway
that's it
that's ridiculous i don't want to rate
it no it doesn't get a raid
[Music]
this is a clip
about one of the most famous highest
ever
in england in 2015
a bunch of senior guys decided to rob a
safety deposit star somewhere in hatton
garden in london they got away with
diamonds and gold world of hundreds of
millions finally they got caught but
still a big part of the loot is gone
can you hear me yeah we can hear there's
someone at the front door
in this scene the alarm goes off and the
car doesn't uh take action
this does happen just a few months ago i
was involved in cracking one of the
biggest archives ever in europe
in 2012 a guy
entered the national gallery in athens
and stole a picasso
he set off the alarm on purpose more
than a hundred times so every time the
guard came looking watching for for an
intruder but he was standing behind the
curtains so after a while the guy
thought there is some technical failure
so he stopped showing up
and at that moment the guy had a few
minutes to steal the picasso and don't
forget 95
percent in another in the netherlands of
the alarm
alarms are uh
are fake yeah when an alarm goes off in
so many cases it's fake because there
was a bird or a curtain
i don't like lookout because
if you have a lookout if if you're
inside you're safe
in the lookout is the one who's hot
because if he walks around people what
was this guy walking around can you
imagine doing that they've been in for
24 hours or longer just one day yeah
if they were in longer
it would have been big but in this case
this guy who was on the lookout even
fell asleep you know yeah but he's hot
you know what are you doing here it's
common for amateurs
but the mistake in this uh robberies was
they were texting
each other with their own phones they
thought they were smart because there is
no phone tap but now everybody knows
about this oh you never call and this
and that you don't do that but i would
rate this movie at 10 because it shows
how it went you know this is one of the
biggest highs ever
it looks like it's worth maybe
30 40 million or something
i don't want to take it from the person
i can see something
that the person is wearing and then
figure out where he lives but not ever
touch anybody but most of these chains
don't even have a lock to open or close
you know and if they have they have
maybe a triple security it doesn't go on
a clock one it has to one two three and
then comes off most of these chains they
go over your head if they're with these
kind of stones you know why do you need
a
lock to open or close it i think this
one is very heavy it's possible to do
this you know you have pickpocket people
who can do this they they take your
watch off you don't even notice any
chain
toilet
private security they will go in nobody
will stop them because they have to be
with their subjects she can't go out of
sight it's impossible that somebody will
stop these two guys in the netherlands
they're not allowed to have private
guards with guns but outside the
netherlands it's allowed most of these
security are ex-military so they have
they know a lot about them what they did
before
if they're disciplined you know if they
can keep them out shot what they see or
noticed
yeah i don't even know why is that
coordinated with all kinds of people you
know put a chain into a soup and then it
goes to a kitchen and if you have the
chain you run out you don't know how we
have to get out somebody gets arrested
they don't find
the stuff on him on her you know they
already passed it along otherwise you're
a suspect then you have to give it to
somebody else i've been to uh monaco to
check these kind of necklaces and
it was possible but i didn't know that
half the city of monaco are cops i
didn't know it's the most secure place
in the world that's true
two cops on every person or something
like that you won't make it i would say
a five
i'll give it a full okay here's the copy
[Music]
all right it's not hard to make a knock
off you know in pearls with diamonds
it's a different thing but the process
is very easy
oh i have a 33 million euro view from
the gentleman over there perhaps
and i don't care if he has an internet
site and he has a lot of money out of
whatever or other auction houses
somebody has to authorize who you are
[Music]
not a lot of people know this but in
1911 the mona lisa was still from the
louvre we have quite a few similarities
i mean he robbed the louvre
rob the van gogh so
only this is fiction i'm real you know i
didn't
watch the lupine series yet because why
should i you know the real lupine
sitting next to me he can tell me the
real story and he had to figure out to
become a person who cleans everything
and you know it's too much it's
unrealistic
all so far
it's spectacular seeing this but of
course it doesn't happen this way i
never did this no
it went down the roof and normally in a
museum the alarm goes off from the roof
you know
in real life you wouldn't do that
because the
i don't know what it is uh grease or
something
if you go over the ground and it's
coming on your clothes that grease will
go everywhere it will go in your getaway
car it will go in your house everywhere
that's why you wouldn't do that he needs
it just to go over the ground i mean why
don't crawl you know why on just a laser
on the ground why another sensor who
takes the whole uh room you know this
it's funny but
normally you go on your stomach and you
crawl
forward i did that
most of the time they are in a square
case you know and it's inside it's not
that you can lift something up in the
the bottom stays there
he grabs the stone with some sort of
gadget i can understand he has to work
from the ground because some sort of
laser or
detector but there is nothing harder
than a diamond you know okay if you take
a slash hammer you will break it but if
you drop this diamond there's no problem
you know it's very hard
you cannot scratch it so
don't worry
the pink panthers they don't leave clues
but what they did for example they stole
uh the screen by monk like 20 years ago
and uh painting 150 million
so they left a note with a smiley and
they said thank you for the bad security
but it's very stupid when you do this
because uh you have cops when you do
that they take it personal and they will
be after you forever when you think it's
over
there's still one going oh you wrote
that letter right wait
they don't like it if you tease them
they're gonna take it personally because
normally a professional won't take that
no that's that's the thing you have to
you have to cut these diamonds you know
they are known so you have to find
someone who can cut them before you can
sell them on the black market or on the
legal market
but when you steal diamonds from a
museum all diamonds especially when they
are
in in some kind of jewelry they are not
really important diamonds so you can you
can't hardly cut them so when people
steal all diamonds they probably didn't
do their homework well
[Music]
it would be better if you would have
shown in this clip
inspector clouseau the clumsy inspector
who is going to have to solve this case
because you know when i track down a
piece of stolen other picasso or
whatever they call me the indiana jones
of art in the media but in reality i'm
more like crousseau you know
like this inspector i follow the wrong
suspects i they
feed me with false leads
when i disguise myself i look more
ridiculous than inspector crusoe when he
was disguised as a pirate with an
inflammable parrot on his shoulder
but we do have one thing in common and
that's that we never give up and nobody
takes him serious but in the end he
cracks the case i would rate this movie
at ten four or five you know i mean
it's to hollywood
[Music]
there you go
they got it right in this movie because
normally in these hollywood movies they
go through the door but nobody goes to
the door it's the most protected part
[Music]
this robbery has something to do with
the case that i sold that was the ring
of oscar wilde was stolen in 2002 in
oxford the university the thief got
caught but he told
police that he had melted the ring down
nobody knew
that he had sold the ring to somebody
and this guy had stored this same ring
in one of these safety deposits in
hatton garden what i'm doing is
profiling you know i'm thinking what
would i have done
uh when they saw short footage of the
burglary one of the
thieves had rainbow socks on rainbow
socks and i said you check that heist
because if it was young guys
they would destroy the ring or they
would sell it or throw it away but only
older men have the respect for the real
value of this ring so it got stolen
again in 2015 of course this guy
couldn't go to the police and say look
they have stolen my oscar aldrin because
it was stolen before i heard rumors on
the market that a certain ring had
appeared
on the market
appearing to be oscar wilde's raymond so
aki came to my home and he said he did
these heists and in many of these saves
he found stolen art you know stolen
jewelry so he gave me the lead and then
i approached these guys these senior
guys
and finally i tracked the ring back
they had sold it because they didn't
know it was the ring of what's going on
they sold it to a jewelry shop
who had sold it to some guy so it shows
that stolen jewels do appear on the
black market in this case even on the
legal market and the recovery rates for
art theft
are very small i think that
around
seven or eight percent is being
recovered the rest disappears forever
i'm just checking for where on the pads
you can work out the code by identifying
the most worn ones i opened doors like
that it's true but then you have to know
the combination because if you have four
times four i don't know how many
combinations you have hundreds
there are different ways to open this
door you don't need a key
he has a
piece of paper i guess uncut key he
pulls it in and when he flips it you
will see the cuts of the mechanism
inside and then cuts it off and then it
will turn now let's give it a 10 a 10
because it really happened and it's
really what they do it's real
this is the famous uh nitrogen
fairly dangerous
if it fails like that on your on your
finger you can break it off i know a few
very
serious burglars that never use this
hey nick
zoe talk to me tell me what you got it's
not here
but the distraction thing is is an
interesting one somebody is
[Music]
threatening to kill himself so everybody
is distracted and this does happen you
know the most famous
uh gang of art thieves in the world are
the pink panthers they are named after
on hollywood film they come from
yugoslavia and this gang has both male
and female members and they do use these
tricks in 2004 in the louvre there was
an antiquities fair and there was a
diamond worth 60 million
dollar it was on display bright lights
security guards but then the wife of the
french minister arrived so everybody
looked for a second the other way and
when they look back
the diamond was gone
in another case they painted a bench in
front of a jewelry shop in miami that
they were about to hit because they
didn't want anybody to sit there and
become a witness on what they do
they use pretty women to distract gods
and all stuff like that so this does
happen if you got a
wrong mechanism inside the whole door
locks you don't open it you won't open
it again you know yeah also for a tree
you know i mean
you get caught if you do it like that
thank you for watching if you want to
see more click the video above